the initial posts of the 1111 you're
gonna be fired up 13 you're gonna be
friggin pissed and I get it this 11 is
gonna change dramatically over the next
couple days this is really really really
important to understand it's not even
close to over we hear it we say it we
believe it but can we see the effect
when games online you can see in a
person's eyes it's noticeable the effect
they make the players around them better
be affected
welcome to the inn factory this was one
of the most epic years of returners guys
that just still want to be a part of
this
I think as they get away from the game
they realize how special and how fun and
unique this was how you doing buddy good
to see you man to see you too
how's Italy treating you good good great
proud of you
Goff was here four years ago like he's
not 37 years like these are four years
ago your age same opportunity didn't win
it was not MVP I don't think he was top
three or four right and like he's we're
never wanting to rich so when you think
about him like opportunity in terms of
where you guys are at pretty crazy this
guy looks like Jared golf
hey Brennan anybody ever told you you
kind of look like golf a little bit
looking at you from distance hey looks
just like Jared you know perfect
preparation equals execution right so we
brought in one of the great coaches in
the pac-12 for a long time Jeff Tedford
to teach them everything he possibly
could about defense in an old Sony
Testament who are you typically studying
for tendency my corner is uptight if
it's dances like this he's gonna bail
okay his eyes are locked on the receiver
what coverage is it man you can tell by
the corners alignment yeah I learn a lot
of defense but you better own your
offense you better learn how to learn
confidence is not hereditary it's not
god-given confidence is like a muscle
there's gonna be a lot of information
you guys are getting a snapshot at this
offense this weekend well pick up on
pure progression first play we're gonna
install gun double right formation
protection pattern
Shawn Clifford attacked the playbook
preparation with vigor he's an ex as a
note junkies a gym rat whatever term you
want to use how this works
for me is I take this playbook one got
it all copied out and then from here you
have to whiteboard and I'm bringing
everything down so I think that's my
eighth factor yes it's a to be able to
chunk a lot of information into little
time I think that I've developed that
skill so you emotion emptied is so it is
meaning we have to type Y Z and then we
have F X here Penn State's getting a
really good one in Sean Clifford and a
kid that's gonna dive in to the process
of being a quarterback as much as
anybody
our ability to process information our
ability to add more information more
confident we get for a quarterback who's
trying to develop the pressure has not
changed the opportunity has not changed
the amount of noise stuff going on
things filling up my head and right in
front of my face and happening to me
it's gone through the roof
body language it matters it makes a
difference when you're out there there's
so much exposure on this position they
have to be a quick to deal with
immediate how do I handle it all their
world has changed they can't be a normal
high school student anymore anytime you
can give an answer to what's happening
behind the scenes they're gonna want to
continue to talked with you and that's
going to help your brand there are the
people we're gonna be watching on
Saturdays the ability for them to
communicate not only on the field but
off the field
that's just invaluable people who are
watching you guys on TV they're not
necessarily listening to the question
they're listening to the answers and I
can't stress that point enough you guys
are the subject Scouts coaches now even
fans be able to dive into you at levels
you cannot even imagine and every single
thing counts the way you walk the way
you talk and nowadays the way you tweet
where you post on Facebook where you
share an Instagram yogi comes up it just
starts about talking about social media
and okay where's this going you know
we're looking at each other what's gonna
happen so our staff we went to work we
know not only tweet you did last night
last week last year the year before the
one you deleted we know all of them yeah
what did I post two years ago I don't
know I don't know and I was really
worried I mean you could tell some
people were confident that when they got
that piece of paper back they were gonna
be fine I was one of those people
because my mom like monitors my Twitter
so
they gave us a sheet of paper there
Twitter Instagram profile picture and
just what we've tweeted over the past
years that we've had social media and
what we could work on you have an
opportunity to impact some of these kids
at their most influential times
Instagram or Twitter I guess you could
say I mean I have a I'm a pretty popular
guy
Tate Martel is most exposed athlete in
this group and he has been since he got
a scholarship offer in eighth grade is
dominated the high school landscape
three high school national championships
almost 50 straight wins he also has I
think a target I mean I have kids that
DM me message me probably four or five
times a day
Tate's like an app look hockey something
he's always saying this and that I was
always responding to it and it's kind of
issue everybody'd for so long told him
it was about him that he didn't know any
different
but - Tate's credit the tape Martel I
saw interact with his fellow competitors
and coaches that's a very different kid
than what he put out there on social
media a few months ago I never really
saw into my parents like Willy sat me
down for one night they're like you got
to chill out like everybody knows how
good you are you don't needed like
protect yourself now I just you know I
blow it off me I had to I have to grow
up and go into college soon I'm super
proud of Tate Martel I think his eyes
been opened to something bigger than
what he's lived or can I think he'll be
even a wiser kid now be even elite 11th
once they figure out that there's an
incredible freedom from letting go of
what other people think of them these
kids are going to go to an entirely
different place sport is a wonderful
opportunity to figure this stuff out
but it is not the end in and of itself
it is part of the journey of you
becoming you so that you can help others
become themselves I think I've grown up
a lot and I've not see like how you're
supposed to handle situations I mean
it's been a great experience for me what
you have been given is extraordinary we
want to honor that so write this down
for those that much is given much is
expected if you did it fine what a real
man was how would you do it we have a
special guest speaker that understands
what it truly means to be a real man
please welcome Alexis Jones to the
Illinois the components we've added to
this event with Alexis Jones and we're
doing our best obviously to provide them
with resources to be the best kids they
can be I'm gonna start with a story
that has to do with the power of the
Jersey there was a girl and her mom they
pulled up at a stoplight here in Los
Angeles before big dude they're leaning
outside of Jeep and they're making all
these like vulgar disgusting gestures
and yelling it at this chick's mom at a
certain point she thought they were
actually getting out of the Jeep the
girl in the car leans over and pulls out
her phone and goes to take pictures cuz
that's the only power she has in that
moment right and so as she drives off
her mom starts crying hysterically pulls
over on the side of the street like
imagine your mom's for a second like
your mom
I don't know who these guys are but like
I hope we find them because these guys
just made my mom cry nine minutes after
posting someone said oh my god
three of the starting players for the
Lakers I'm just gonna randomly pass
these out I don't want you to turn these
over yet so the crazy part of the story
is that chick was me they go from the
kind of I'm too cool for school to the
oh my gosh so those of you who have a
piece of paper we flip it over because
this was the response that I got online
they're numbered so number one put a gun
to her head and kill the dead body just
to remind her of her place hashtag real
man someone showing this mouth to shut
her up you'll find it
Alexis kind of left everybody's jaws on
the ground
a real man needs to put you in your
place until you can't walk hey do you
have a daughter soccer rhythm shoot I
can't wait until you have a daughter so
I can reap them too you see them
wrestling with it like you see them
confronting the own monsters that exist
inside their head there's some magic
that happens in those moments we will
write you on your mom to give you
something to talk about I think for me
coming in and expanding and broadening
the it factor that it also has to do
with grace and with humility and all of
these other things to get them thinking
of the impact that they could have which
isn't just how well they play ball but
is actually the caliber of man that they
choose to be having a sister and a mom
and aunt and my grandparents mean it
just hit me so much more sighs such a
good relationship with him I almost
cried Ryan fire everybody I was sitting
out like holding it back the whole time
it really hit me like to be honest I
like I wanted to go give her a hug after
you stupid or I hope you die hashtag
Lakers for life that's the power of the
jersey you have the ability to ignite a
mob
you